China is warning the u.s. and North
Korea that a war will have no winner
after the North threatened to shoot down
American warplanes North Korea was
responding to President Trump's recent
tweet that its leadership won't be
around much longer North Korea's foreign
minister called those words a
declaration of war a new CBS News poll
finds 53 percent of Americans are
concerned President Trump might start an
unnecessary war Ben Tracy is in Beijing
Ben good morning good morning so the
fear has been that President Trump's
tweets or threats could be
misinterpreted by Kim jong-un and that
could lead to some sort of unintended
military conflict it's not clear if
that's what's happening here or if by
saying the u.s. is declared war North
Korea is playing some sort of game North
Korea says it now has the right to shoot
down American warplanes even if they're
flying outside North Korean airspace
international laws as a country's
airspace extends about 13 miles out to
sea but North Korea claims more than a
70-mile zone this past weekend American
bombers and fighter jets flew 200 miles
off North Korea's East Coast the
furthest North American warplanes have
gone this century that in part led North
Korea's foreign minister to issue
another threat he said all options are
now on the table for his country's
supreme leadership u.s. intelligence
says there are indications Kim jong-un
could test another intercontinental
ballistic missile in the next five to
ten days a Simon North Korean leader is
still moving forward with his weapons
program
despite US warnings and punishing
sanctions if we think sanctions will get
North Korea to give up nuclear weapons
right away we're wrong
Michael green worked at the National
Security Council during the George W
Bush administration we now know and
anyone who's worked on North Korea or
negotiated with them now knows they are
not serious in any way about a
diplomatic negotiation to give up their
nuclear weapons
the South Korean intelligence said today
that North Korea did not immediately
respond when those u.s. warplanes were
off its Coast this past weekend that
could be an indication that North Korea
did not detect them but North Korea has
since strengthened its coastal defenses
Charlie
Ben Tracy in Beijing thanks Ben